Well, I did say this was a bit of a trick.
If you look carefully at this regular expression, it requires words that are at least two letters long,
a through z followed by one or more a through z at least two.
So, we actually don't match a. We match quick and brown and then there's nothing in here.
We just return a two-element list.
We have questions like this, because I want you to be confident in your own answer
and not necessarily trust the structure of the problem that's given to you.
This particular phrase a quick brown comes from the sentence,
"A quick brown fox jumps over the lazy dog,"
used commonly because it typically involves all of the letters in the English alphabet
giving you a chance to see what each one looks like if you're testing out a font or what not.
So here is my quick brown fox, and it's jumping over a lazy dog,
and we will say that this sentence labels both of them.